hello everyone and welcome back to
Rotten Tomatoes is wrong it's your girl
Jacqueline I'm here alongside my
favorite person to talk movies with Mr
Mark Ellis and we're in studio we did it
two weeks in a row thus far it's an
unbroken streak we have not burned the
building down yet surprisingly
surprisingly although the characters in
the movie we're talking about today
probably already would have set fired
incorporating some stunt there would
have been samurai swords there would
have been one of them bearing the other
one yeah this is one of the all-time
most anticipated episodes ever for this
show for me anyway Jacqueline and for me
as well look I remember the first day my
boss Joel like messaged me at the time
and he was like hey I think we're gonna
do a podcast based on the book and the
book was you know how to embrace your
rotten movies that we love and Step
Brothers cult classics underrated gems
and films that are so good is the cover
of this amazing cover Rotten Tomatoes
rotten movies we love and honestly the
fact that we haven't done this yet is
just so surprising to me but I'm so glad
we're finally gonna get to talk Step
Brothers with the guy who I think the
very first time I met him made a joke
about the Catalina wine mixer I'm not at
all thinking that I think it's on videos
that his former employers like I think
you can check this out Mr Hal rugnik
comedian co-host of the binge boys
podcast with Lon Harris another friend
of the Pod and I will also say one of
the best stand-up improvisers he still
teaches classes here in La Mr Hal
rednick sir welcome to the Pod damn good
to be here the only other place I'd
rather be is the Catalina wine mixer
getting drunk on wine flying helicopters
playing Billy Joel covers oh my goodness
uh yeah a pleasure to be here with you
and Mark well you know the Catalina wine
mixer was not a thing they made it up
for the movie but since the movie came
out that's one of the many just facets
of popularity that the the Step Brothers
has funneled itself into manifesting out
of thin air and actual annual event
called the Catalina wine mixer I don't
know if they sell helicopters there but
they do have and you gotta think that
there's 80s Billy Joel cover bands I
don't know if they're from Central
California but you have 80s Billy Joel
cover bands it's got to be part of the
Catalina wine mixer I mean it has to be
there's so many great moments for this
movie and we're definitely going to get
into it the reason why we're getting
into it is because spirited which is
coming out on 11 18 on Apple TV plus
Stars Will Ferrell Ryan Reynolds and
Octavia Spencer this is sort of our way
to talk about a great Will Ferrell movie
that we love so and there have been tons
of requests for it Mark mostly by me
yeah yeah mostly by you mark then how
before we get into chatting about this
can you as best you can tell us the plot
and what is the happenings of Step
Brothers well yeah since uh our our
viewers and our listener are not going
to be able to follow Hal and I driving
around La for the rest of the day which
is pretty much the plot of Step Brothers
yeah here's how it works so you have
Dale and Brennan and they both come from
single parent homes and those parents lo
and behold fall in love at a conference
they meet each other they say well
there's you know the one thing I'm I'm
in love with you but I have this kid and
uh not exactly a teenager anymore just
kind of acts like that and it ends up
being John C Riley and Will Ferrell they
meet they're living Under One Roof
they're not necessarily the best of
friends until a few incidents bounce
certain ways and they discover not only
are they getting along did we just
become best friends yup thanks oh yeah
mostly to the love of Metallica and
samurai swords and getting Randy
Jackson's autograph on said samurai
sword their Adventures ensue they
overcome some obstacles including
siblings including siblings wives who
may be in love with one of them yeah
including falling out of tree houses and
therapy and all these other things that
sort of issue you into away from your
adolescence into your adulthood and it
all ends up at the Catalina a wine mixer
what's gonna happen in that climactic
sequence the band gets kicked off stage
we need somebody to rescue it here come
Dale and Brennan I love this so much
that is
honestly sir can I just say uh that is a
certified fresh summary that is a
certified friendship then it's better
than the movie I know I was about to say
55 rotten and a 69 audience score but
the way you described it 75 and above I
just want to make sure everyone
understands what was the audience score
again 69
exactly the score this movie should have
Bill and Ted improved 55 rotten this is
actually one that like it could it could
find enough reviews on like DVD and
streaming to where it might one day push
ahead but right now it's a little engine
that yeah it's close enough there's a
couple of movies that we did like that
like the sand lot was like the 58 59.
Spaceballs is now fresh it is when this
book came out I remember I was
moderating a panel for it in New York
City at Comic-Con and Spaceballs at the
time was 59 and I was like oh this is so
close we just need a couple more reviews
now Spaceballs is like 61 62 Sister Act
2 as we mentioned last week
yeah and I think I'm not going to say
that it is all about us here at Rotten
Tomatoes is wrong but it is a testament
to how these movies rise in estimation
and when we really think about like
again the podcast and everything
involved in it this this is the this is
the movie that I always want to say so
how I'll start with you sir is Rotten
Tomatoes wrong about Step Brothers just
give it to me straight 100 absolutely
wrong that I mean the critics who called
this movie uh that said it was uh rotten
they are they have no Joy inside they're
they're their inner child
um perished some who hurt them and
actually I have a list of a few of the
critics that I would like to call out
right now yes absolutely
Chris receipts Christopher Tookie of the
Daily Mail in the UK not a favorite
publication yeah you're in the UK and
also you wrong you you fumbled the ball
uh Cosmo landisman you're no Cosmo
Kramer sir of the you know what's in the
water in England was it brexit they you
know they eliminated the ability to
enjoy good
old-fashioned comedy history in England
I don't know why this movie didn't
capture them like Johnny English might
have right or or a Mr Bean uh Lindy west
of The Stranger in Seattle Washington
you are a stranger to humor my friend uh
Michael Smith of Tulsa World
um Oklahoma's okay but your take on Step
Brothers how are you before you get the
entire critical Community to hate us I
don't care I am here to I brought
receipts I'm calling it out I am going
scorched Earth Rotten Tomatoes is damn
funny I love this so much
um Mark very quickly I'm just gonna take
your quick take on this one before we go
into Tim ice Rotten Tomatoes here's 10
critics that I would like to call out by
this continue I will say thank you to
Justin rothkop I believe is the
gentleman's name who wrote the review of
Step Brothers in rotten movies we love
so it's his essay in the book that is
defending it and I will agree with one
Jonah Hill who says that he feels that
Step Brothers is the modern comedy
classic of our time it's the all-time
best modern comedy film he's ever seen
absolutely do believe it and and to me
like Blues Brothers this is the Blues
Brothers of Our Generation just that
perfect comedy movie that does the
critics didn't care about it yeah but it
just keeps on chuggling throughout the
generation I like it and so I agree with
that but let's not just imagine what the
critics were saying let's go ahead and
turn it to our favorite segment our view
curation manager it's Mr Tim Ryan two
minutes with Tim take it away
[Music]
we had Rotten Tomatoes published a book
a couple years ago called rotten movies
we love the image on the cover is from
Step Brothers It's Will Ferrell and John
C Reilly flailing their arms and making
silly faces while jumping into a pool
and it's the kind of movie made for our
book and this podcast as well Step
Brothers did well at the box office but
it got mixed to negative reviews upon
its release including a famous pan by
Roger Ebert but the people who love it
love it and its stature has grown over
the years of course critics can never be
sure how a film will be embraced by an
audience and even its fans would admit
the movie can be silly and juvenile but
in his essay about Step Brothers in
rotten movies we love Entertainment
Weekly senior editor Joshua rothkoff
argued that there's more to that
silliness in juvenalia than meets the
eye he wrote asking us to accept these
awkward boy men and we do through a
stupefied veil of train wreck magnetism
and the distant recognition of our own
12 year old cells stepbrothers ends up
making a mockery of adulthood and that's
quietly radical stepbrothers is rotten
at 55 on the Tomato Meter with 203
reviews and it has a 67 audience score
so what did the critics have to say in a
rotten review Joe Morgenstern The Wall
Street Journal wrote there's a good
subject for satire here the extended
adolescence of American kids but satire
presupposes maturity or at least some
perspective however in a fresh review
Matt whites of the Dallas Morning News
wrote the engine that drives this flick
is the chemistry between Mr Riley and Mr
Farrell the two obviously Delight in
each other's company and it feels good
and funny to watch the Rotten Tomatoes
critics consensus reads Step Brothers
indulges in a cheerfully Relentless
immaturity that will quickly turn off
viewers unamused by feral and Riley and
Delight those who find their Antics
hilarious so that's Step Brothers let's
kick it back to Jacqueline and Mark each
of whom have been called the Songbird of
their Generation by people who've heard
them that good back to you Tim I just
love hearing his voice I love the fact
that we're back in studio and I really
really love that we're talking about
this movie but do we even care what the
critics like we've already established
we don't care about about what they say
on this particular one but there were
some critics who liked it and I do
appreciate that Tim calls them out as
well yeah and and I feel like the
problem with comedy is that it's more so
than any other genre it's the beauty is
in the eye of the beholder right yeah
and I will admit once we get into movie
talk that I had my own misgivings about
Step Brothers when the movie was being
advertised so I wasn't sure how this
movie was going to play out but like
anything else we like having our opinion
validated and so when we'd watch sitcoms
back in the day okay your your friends
your Martin your Seinfeld you heard a
studio audience laugh and that made us
feel like oh okay now that ratifies that
what I think is funny is funny with the
masses and so when you see a movie
that's that's well reviewed it's a
comedy doesn't matter what comedy it is
it could be something like like
Bridesmaids like Monty Python and the
Holy Grail it's like oh I'm glad the
critics are on the same page it makes
you feel validated I just don't feel
validated by the rotten score for
stepbrother yeah I would say you know
this comedy is uh subjective and you
know a lot of comedy can be an acquired
taste and this movie you know it is low
brow comedy much of it it's not uh
Armando iannucci's in the loop it's uh
it's it's not Peak Albert Brooks or
something like that it's not Defending
Your Life you know it but it goes for it
it commits and it's in a proud tradition
I think you can hearken back to uh
people like you know uh Jerry Lewis
Peter Sellers and the pink Panther
movies
um Steve Martin in The Jerk Pee-wee
Herman peewee's big adventure like goofy
doofus goofing around characters and
they have the pedal to the metal uh
playing those archetypes in this movie
there's sometimes when committing to the
bit is good sometimes when it's bad and
unfortunately a comedian only knows it
in his rearview mirror but I do
appreciate it that this was this is one
of the good examples and with that let's
go ahead and take it on to our movie
talk where we can break down just all
the incredible quotes and all the iconic
scenes Brian cue the music
[Music]
and we are back okay Hal I'm gonna start
with you sir when did you first see Step
Brothers because I did not see this one
in the theaters okay this is weird I'm
not proud to admit this because I didn't
see it in the theaters either I saw it
in bits and pieces on cable I would just
join it I would just jump in like it
would be a moving train and I'd grab on
and I'd be like oh yeah I'm in I'm along
for the ride and finally I kind of
pieced it together and now I've watched
it in its entirety but I just knew like
you could jump it's like it's one of
those movies like uh Goodfellas where
you can just hop in anywhere and it's
like you know what this is too good to
leave it was like joining a classic
episode of Saturday Night Live already
in progress where you just knew the next
sketch was gonna kill and you didn't
necessarily need any connective tissue
with the plot because there is a plot
here as I aptly described when we kicked
off the show but it's not that necessary
to just have laughs because you can put
on for instance one of the most watched
scenes from this film on YouTube I think
it's got like 15 million views on its
own is the Sweet Child of Mine rendition
by Adam Scott who plays the brother the
the [ __ ] brother and his family yes
he just makes them perform it perfectly
to a T and that's funny independent of
anything else going on watching Dale and
Brennan go at it is funny watching
Richard Jenkins and Mary steenberg and
who are the parents in this movie Very
undervalued I would say a straight man
comedic forces in this movie too
absolutely there's so much and it's
funny that neither one of you all saw
this in theaters because neither did I
wow I came to it the same way how
Rudnick did where you just see bits and
pieces like this is really funny and I
was apprehensive about this film because
I think anchorman's a great movie okay
Anchorman and Anchorman the Legend
Continues for that matter I think
they're both very funny but I was
walking out of the first Anchorman movie
which I did see in the theater and I
just thought like that is a movie I'm
gonna want to re-watch in 10 minute
bursts I don't necessarily want to sit
down and watch the whole movie because I
just can't take that amount of pure
idiocy for that long and so I thought
Step Brothers is going to be the same
way but Step Brothers just has this
weird quality that I can't really put my
finger on Jacqueline that just makes it
endlessly rewatchable and you want to
start at the beginning and you want to
go on this full journey I don't exactly
know why but man I I care about these
people well Against All Odds I mean look
so I didn't see it the way that you guys
saw it I actually saw it in an even
stranger setting which is that I think
it was four years later for me or three
years later in 2010 is when I moved back
from Dallas back to Austin and that
weekend I did not have a couch I did not
have anything I had a bed and I had a
room and my two best girlfriends from
college came down to Austin we went to
the Austin City Limits music festival
and if you've ever been to music
festivals you know at the end of the
night you're tired
um and things that you can toasty a
little time oh yeah you need to
decompress and these girls put on Step
Brothers and I kept them up all evening
just laughing woke up the next morning
being like she's got a smile
and they were so done with me they were
so done with me they were like this was
the wrong movie we should have played
her something to calm her down not to
Hype her up because she is so not in so
Katie Courtney love y'all uh I think
that's why that movie works is such a
great party kind of movie too it's
because you don't have to follow Every
Beat of it yeah you can see a scene you
can drift out you can come down
bangers one after another both of you
have mentioned the amazing Sweet Child
scene which is held Aloft it's gorgeous
Catherine Han because much is what Adam
Scott is doing I we were gonna get down
to this a second actually I want to hold
off on this because I want to give
everyone their due and I want to
basically first start with the film so
hold off on the Sweet Child of Mine
scene but
should the movie be fresh and why do you
think it wasn't Fresh So I uh as I said
before I 100 believe that this movie
should be fresh why do I think it wasn't
fresh I think you know we were kind of
hit a couple of the thoughts that comedy
is subjective and that it is Goofy I
feel like critics thought oh this is so
dumb it can't be good rather the and
they let that cloud their Vision because
I actually think this is a well-told
story of these brothers these Step
Brothers who are Rivals then they come
together then they're forced to grow up
and if I could take it to a slightly
deeper level which uh the the brothers
they they find joy in the end yeah and
this movie is a Clarion call for you to
follow your passion your joy to smell
the roses and look at the Burks who work
for Adam Scott's and Rob Riggles company
like they follow the money and they're
evil they're mean and they're not happy
at the end of the day whereas these two
these two innocent gems they follow
their passion and they find Joy at the
end so people out there listening follow
your joy and you can be as happy as a
Dale and Brennan it's the scene that we
see at the end when Richard jenkins's
character is finally coming around to
who these kids are and who they have
been the whole time when he says oh my
God this is me before I give up my dream
of being a dinosaur yes and pursue an
adult job he just wanted to be a
dinosaur and so I will take it a step
further than Mr running do it Step
Brothers is the best filmed version of
Peter Pan that we have ever seen very
very true because everybody else was
Peter Pan at one we all were yes then
you grew up and you forgot how to fly
Dale and bread and never stopped flying
or in their case hitting each other with
shovels and defending their drum sets
with their very lives hell yeah that's
why I do comedy you know yeah I I love
it and uh yeah do not become a wage
slave do not become just beholden to
capitalism you know what give up all
your worldly possessions and Go full
Dale and Brennan everybody I mean can I
just be like the woman at the table to
say cautionary tale there's an entire
generation of men who followed this
advice too carefully did not go to
therapy and now we have the dating
situations that we have now just
remember do all the things that you guys
did but remember these two guys were
also in therapy when they decided to do
that so chase your dreams but get a good
therapist you know what this movie is no
this movie is like the more modern day
version of Wall Street yeah where you
had a character who you're not
necessarily supposed to be modeling your
life after but they're so charismatic or
they're so funny in the case of Step
Brothers that everybody after Wall
Street came out wanted to be like
Michael Douglas even though Gordon Gekko
is clearly the villain of yeah that
movie came out Pat Riley starts slicking
his hair back on the wake of Silence
everybody wanted to look like that
that's true Brothers comes out and it's
like oh this is the way it's not
necessarily the way to model your life
but it is a nice reminder to keep some
of that youthful joy that you had and
try to bring it to adulthood but the
other thing about this movie and the
reason why I think it's rotten according
to the critics still is that you can
take comedy and you can call it highbrow
or low brow but there seems to be
something where you have folks that show
up to a movie set and the movie feels
largely improvised that I think
sometimes we feel like they weren't
trying as hard that they just showed up
and wanted to make a movie with their
friends both things can be true where
you do want to make a movie with a bunch
of your pals but I feel like this is a
much better example of a film that works
like that as opposed to grown-ups which
is more scripted feeling and it's all
those friends who just want to hang out
and make a movie right here I feel like
they really thought they could do
something special yeah and I think they
did the other thing I will say too is
this was one of the first movies that
was very open about the fact that they
did all this improvisation and what
we've seen later is that a lot of movies
have tried this and they don't have the
same results because you have to have a
team of very talented improvisers but
also a very smart director who knows
just the right line to say to get the
joke back like that's the part of this
that doesn't get seen as much but I've
been witness to some of these sets and
it's really like you know Judd or Adam
or whoever these directors are just
being like all right say this say this
say this and then maybe the improviser
is like well how about I tweak it this
way and it really is a chef like putting
in a little bit more ingredients here a
little bit ingredients there and so
you're only as good as your Sous chefs
and I think the films where they have
really great Sous chefs you get really
great iconic lines and the ones that you
don't you don't and this one is a
perfect example of like I don't know how
many lines Adam is credited to the
actors on the day but as many from
himself do you have a favorite one that
you know is either improvise or just one
that you kind of live by from this one
oh man a favorite line from this movie
uh it's so hard to narrow down because
anytime you start talking about Step
Brothers the lines just sort of fly back
and forth It's like you play you play
line tennis you do play lion tennis I do
like Catherine Hahn being like I just I
I don't want to talk about this like and
like her give up and I don't want to be
here when he starts yelling at her is my
favorite just her just like I can't
anymore with you her performance in this
movie gets better every time I see it
she is she's perfect yes in every scene
in this film as just this beleaguered
downtrodden wife who just yearns The
Break Free hopefully with John C Riley
the scene when that when they're just
imagining themselves in the forest and
he's like a centaur and it comes it's
just it's so good I think she says like
I can't believe I slept with you or like
I can't believe I let you impregnate me
like I think that's the line that I'm
like I'm still about the the movie
starts off strong and stays strong
comedically the entire way and one of
like I was just uh re-watching some of
it uh before I came in and one of the
lines that I didn't remember but I was
like that is amazing when John C Reilly
is talking to Richard Jenkins and he's
like all right what if uh what if your
uh your wife gets out of the shower and
then uh or I get out of the shower and
like my hair is glistening my pubes are
glistening and she's like okay I've
tried the bull now I want to try the cat
and I'm like that is horrific
nightmarish and amazing yeah the the
great line that there's two lines that I
think of when I think of this movie and
for whatever reason it's there there's
the scene where they're riding home from
the birthday dinner where Dale and
Brennan have made their presentation yes
for Prestige Worldwide to be this Tower
company they made a video that they
played at the dinner and it ends up with
Richard jenkins's boat getting wrecked
and so he's Furious they're driving home
Dale and Brenner in the back seat and
they just they're like cut the crap are
you investing or not
I think that they've made this amazing
video presentation but piggybacking off
that I think part of the reason why this
movie works for me even more than
Anchorman does is because the Anchorman
pardon the pun never has that reality
anchor that you feel that you do have in
this movie because of the parents
because of Mary steenberg and being down
to earth and Richard Jenkins those are
relatable characters those are those
feel like real parents to me yes who
just were busy and they lost their
partner and you just have to raise a kid
all by yourself and just do the best you
can this was the result for each of them
and so you feel the pain you feel The
Angst and comedy is pain Christmas time
comes around it's clear that these two
have sort of wrecked whatever beautiful
vision for the future that Mary and
Richard had and so it's Christmas time
and Richard Jenkins is so upset with
what his life has become they're talking
about Christmas and he just says the
known in particular I think we're gonna
go down to the Cheesecake Factory
that scene that that the line delivery
murders yes I frequented throughout the
holidays I also have to say to Richard
Jenkins and Mary they are playing quote
unquote straight men but the straight
men that unravel and that is such a hard
pull because you have to gauge how far
the kettle is boiling through each
minute of each scene and so when he does
do his like what's that's not that's the
Whistle the kettle is whistling you know
what I mean but it hasn't like got
insisted yet I'm going down the
Cheesecake Factory and as someone who I
think has made it no
um any way of secret that I really do
appreciate chain restaurants like the
Cheesecake Factory and TGI Fridays me
and Mark were raised in southern cities
where that was fine dining oh yeah you
know what I mean and you can take the
girl out the country
at the girl let me throw a question uh
out to both you Richard Jenkins who has
just been killing it for decades
um I he just I was watching spooky
season I was watching some Halloween
movies and he popped up in Witches of
Eastwick and I'm like damn there's
Richard Jenkins with more hair but a
question for both of you
um he plays a disappointed father in
this film he's also a different kind of
disappointed father in the Netflix uh
mini-series Dahmer who do you think
which father is more disappointed in
their son
I'll take your and his uh word on that
one I
um have not watched that show and I I'm
look I'm an awards editor so I'm sure at
some point I'm gonna have to watch it
and read it but the range that that guy
has yeah you can't make him do straight
drama with with the best of them but the
first time I saw Richard Jenkins and
remembered oh this is who this guy is
was as the therapist at the beginning of
There's Something About Mary yes where
did you have that little scene but it's
really funny and then you also hear his
voice in a serious film like Spotlight
yeah he's the one on the phone you never
see him but he's it's his voice
recounting how many priests he think
have actually done this and it's just
such like a sturring moment just the
fact that that guy could convey that but
then you put him in this movie and when
he's yelling at them and he's calling
them you wrecked my boat you goon it
that that having that as the ground lets
Will Ferrell and John C Reilly be as
hilarious as moronic and as as not in
touch with reality as possible because
we buy something about this movie I
think that is a really important point
for why Step Brothers is so it still
works today absolutely that and and the
white dog
Chris gardaki makes him lick the white
dog turd man like that one right there
that was when I knew this movie like I
was feeling straight fairly Brothers I
was like there is no line for where this
movie's going to go and it honestly
talks to the Brilliance of McKay and
Farrell as both producing partners and
creative partners with John C Reilly
more as a star of a lot of the movies
obviously but just that was in my
personal opinion and I was like okay
these guys are doing it at a different
level it makes me lament that their
partnership is over now just considering
I hope you get it back yeah yeah
if you know that uh some relationships
are irrevocably broken and this
relationship is irrevocable it's yeah
it's hard for me to relate because I'm
Friends With All My Exes as you know I
do all two of them
good good friends still to this day you
know I don't think John C Reilly and I
love your opinions on this gets enough
credit as a comedic Beast yeah I mean
the guy who has range like Jenkins
Johnson in the same class absolutely
yeah I love Steve Brule Steve like uh
doc um Dr Steve Rule for your health uh
it's so good John C Riley yeah the man
can do anything this is what I would say
so do Steve Brule do Step Brothers and
then go watch him in Chicago like that's
the part like Mr Cellophane like this
heartbreaking number that lives and dies
by that performance you have to be very
good to be able to pull that off and be
able to do you know shake and bake did
we just become best friends it is on a
different level we need to talk about
Kevin yes Dad and Dad what a double
feature that is another one next to the
adventures of Ricky Bobby oh yeah
because that's another one and I think
that people need to go back and
appreciate the Ricky Bobby's and the
Step Brothers of the world anymore it
particularly given what we saw with
Holmes and Watson where it's like it
just for whatever it just ain't there
yeah it's not the same and that's a
movie that I that I understand critics
going to and being like you just put
these guys in a scenario and just assume
that we all thought it would be great
great and so I think that there's a lot
more tender loving care that went into
making Step Brothers and that's why it
still holds up to all of these repeat
viewings the iconic scene for me in Step
Brothers even more so than the Catalina
wine mix or any particular line is when
they're discovering their similarities
and how close friends that they could be
did we just become best friends they
immediately run into their parents room
and every at least for me my brother
that was me and my brother we were kids
you think of an idea you no no Creator
as a kid is going to think of a good
idea before 11 pm at night so you come
up with something great late night like
putting our beds in into bunk beds you
run in your parents room you declare
this great idea they do not care they
just want to go to bed they have job
interviews the next day and so their
parents are like yeah whatever they make
their bunk beds there's so much more
room for aerobics they crash in and
activities and activities yeah and it
simplifies like uh you know men are dumb
animals and it really simplifies like
and but uh it typifies the connection
that guys can have like the Simplicity
of it like you like fantasy football I
like fantasy football you like The
Avengers I like the Avengers let's hang
let's drink brewski I I think uh earlier
uh Jacqueline brought up a great point
in talking about these dudes uh not
being in touch with their feelings the
Failure to Launch aspect of these guys
and uh you know that kind of triggers in
my mind there was like one scene
thinking back on the film that I feel
like really didn't age well to me and
it's when Will Ferrell is sitting with
his therapist Andrea Savage and he's
really trying to like sexualize her and
like take the relationship to the next
level I'm like that didn't quite age
well just dudes well but it's very
accurate most men fall in love with
their female therapist it's actually
like a very common thing because
basically this is the first woman that
they've ever interacted with on an
intimately emotional level yeah she's
asking them questions they've never
heard as much as that's a horrible bit
of Comedy as again someone that's been
in way too much therapy if you ask my
family that that tracks like not me but
like that is a very common thing for
therapists to say especially when
dealing with men they haven't had anyone
ask them about their feelings since they
were four and like the last person to do
it was their mom it's like a
transference thing it's like a very it's
not saying that the scene holds up
better because of it it's not something
that I think you can portray to wider
audiences without that level of nuance
but is that some stuff that happens yeah
well you wish that character would would
progress a little bit because there is
that there's a turn in the movie where
they're down and out and they're on
their own and they have to grow up a
little bit and so and it works great
where one of them buys toilet paper by
themselves and it's just like yeah I did
it and then the other one is doing their
taxes with the Chewbacca head on and
then decides maybe I don't need the
Chewbacca head yeah to do taxes and
they're talking when they have that that
initial exchange at the Catalina wine
mixer where they're trying to talk like
adults yeah and it and it just feels a
little weird and stifle but they're but
they're making gonna go of it because
these are guys who have been raised in
this world where everything that they
watch is them is is men leading and so
when they're at the job interviews and
they're wearing tuxes and and Will
Ferrell tells the the one young lady to
shut your mouth shut your mouth you
sound so that's just the way that they
grew up thinking this is how you talk
you know you could watch a James Bond
movie in the 60s and then you can go to
a job interview and feel like oh is that
not how I'm supposed to act as a as a
Debonair man about town it's the thing
about the movie that I really want
people to not forget is they get the
reason why this movie is so iconic the
reason why it lives in our hearts and
Minds is not because these were two
buffoons doing buffoonery it's because
they gather some emotional intelligence
by the end of it and realize the Havoc
that they're reeking on their families
and like if it's just two buffoons it's
funny but it's not something that you
can't follow the movie and I think
that's house point where where you'd see
scenes of it on TV and then you're like
I I kind of I'm laughing at this
particular moment and it works great as
a sketch in the same way that Anchorman
does but that's why I feel like this is
a move this is a better film than then
anchor there's an evolution here the
characters grow and yeah there's a
timeline of that relationship that helps
you follow the movie I wouldn't say the
second Anchorman is the better example
of that like the second Anchorman you
see more growth from Ron Burgundy than
you do right you know what I mean and I
think that's a indicative of these
collaborations between Will Ferrell John
C Reilly you see a progression even in
their uh relationships as they dig
deeper I mean the the big short to going
back to this and further back the you
can make these lines uh it makes me
think for you guys uh let's go ahead and
go between John C Reilly Will Ferrell
and Adam McKay what do you think is
their best effort and this is a long
list to choose from but uh how do you
want a minute are you gonna go first
I'll give you Will Ferrell first I think
he's the easier one to pick oh for uh
Will Ferrell his best effort well you
know Will Ferrell's never made me laugh
harder that and this is just one scene
uh in Old School where he gets shot in
the neck with a tranquilizer
um I don't know if I've ever laughed
harder in a movie theater than Will
Ferrell and an old school yeah uh and
then you know Anchorman is right there
as far as old school for myself too just
because that movie I felt Not only was
Will Ferrell great but everyone around
him made him better and they were also
look you got Luke with like you know you
you go home or you take the early flight
home like he gets a comedic moment like
that I feel like everybody gets their
best comedic work Vince Vaughn that top
swingers which to me I always thought
that would be his best yeah old school
hit so hard right out of the gate too
with that wedding scene where it's at
Vince Vaughn is actively trying to talk
him out of getting married as she's
walking down the aisle and it was just
such a shocking opening then you get the
reception with The Dan Band and seeing
willfare on that movie I think that that
movie it sticks out in all of our heads
when we saw because I saw that one in a
theater and it's because you were sort
of waiting for the next SNL cast member
to pop as a movie star and you're
waiting for who from this cast is going
to emerge because Adam Sandler and Mike
Myers were already like making you know
Eddie Murphy the generation before who's
going to be it from this class then you
saw old school and you're like oh Will
Ferrell's the guy the guy I mean he is
he's stealing every scene in this movie
and then Anchorman comes out but I still
have this move I have Step Brothers as
Will Ferrell's funniest effort I have it
as Adam McKay's best I love The Big
Short I that succession is a great show
that he produces I'm excited for his
take on the January 6th film that he's
that he's coming out with but for me
Step Brothers again and particularly in
light of other projects that they've all
gone on to since then that just haven't
hit for whatever reason has hardest Step
Brothers I think it makes it makes this
film stand the test of time even more
and so I'd put it up there with John C
Riley but again the guy has such range
that he can disappear into another role
and be dramatic and not and you're not
thinking about Step Brothers or Steve
Brule yeah I think for me I would
definitely go with Chicago for um for
John C Riley I know that's like
sacrilegious to all of y'all listening I
can hear your groans through my
earphones right now but listen I am a
musical girl first and I worship Rob
Marshall for that movie and John C
Reilly has one of the best Show Stoppers
of the musical where Catherine Zeta
Jones literally like takes off her
clothes and dances halfway through it
like come on like this is like this is
something I will live for Mr Cellophane
cue it up on YouTube definitely old
school for Will Ferrell Adam McKay I'm
gonna go to The Big Short he put Margot
Robbie in a bathtub and had her explain
cdos y'all yeah that is genius pretty
good way to learn about economics
exactly he sort of defined his voice and
his take on serious uh on a more uh
serious subject matter also I think Vice
is underrated Christian Bale's
performance like I think he should have
won over Rami Malek the Academy Award
that I would agree with you on that one
but uh and for John C Reilly Steve Brule
is my spirit animal like uh Steve Brule
like I just uh yeah I Vibe with him so
hard
I'll give some love to another movie
that I think is unfairly rotten and was
just kind of missed in theaters but it's
found a cult following senses Walk Hard
oh yes he's just he's the perfect
casting for that Johnny Cash type
character but it's also such a goofy
spoof ridiculous comedy but he owns
every scene and and it's the commitment
I mean you see the commitment from him
and Will Ferrell to just make these
characters feel 3D even though clearly
you just read and you're like these are
just two buffoons why do we even care
about it they're inhabiting it with with
authentic emotion it may be from a
bygone era it may be very adolescent or
even infantile but it's it's still you
feel that they actually care that
they're actually good people at heart
yeah I will say it's not an Aragon buy I
just uh this past weekend little name
drop moderated the press conference were
weird and so it was like Daniel
Radcliffe and that movie is in the vein
of Dewey walks but takes it to a totally
another level in the best of best of
best of ways
um it's such a like when I when you
mentioned Dewey Cox Walk Hard I
definitely thought about that because
this idea idea of a parody biopic but
still I think you can see the reality
that they spoof off of and that's the
best part but let me ask you all
something because it feels like these
films that are mostly improvised or feel
that they're they lean heavily on
improvisation whether it's this whether
it's pop star or is anything else that
would walk Hard it feels like those get
unfairly maligned by critics yet shows
like Curb Your Enthusiasm which I find
hysterical and it's largely improved as
well Feels Like That Gets wadded By by
critics so where is the disconnect there
like I guess I need somebody I've been
doing standard for 15 years I need
somebody to explain to me why Curb Your
Enthusiasm is more highbrow or feels
more highbrow than
then Step Brothers I think Hal can speak
to this one because of the medium like
sitcoms are theater
and movies aren't and so I think people
like for me personally I feel like the
reason why they do it with the shows is
because of this the concept of like like
uh sitcoms as we see them is like an
audience situation watching it laugh
track type stuff that's theater that's
what that's intended to be whereas in
movies it's such a longer setup for that
sort of like Vaudeville type comedy call
back it can seem cheap on the bigger
setting and I think yeah also I feel
like The Meta nature of Curb Your
Enthusiasm that uh Larry David is
spoofing his own Persona adds a level of
thoughtfulness perhaps to it and you
feel a little bit like a voyeur watching
it like oh is Larry David really friends
with 10 Ted Danson
um and is uh is his agent really similar
to uh Jeff Garland's big uh like lout so
there's something about that and then
the the it's the longevity of it and the
heights it reached with like the
Seinfeld season where they brought the
cat members back so Curb Your Enthusiasm
I don't I you know I don't know like if
you went back to the beginning if it was
beloved by critics the way it is now but
just the staying power and everything
also you know when you're talking about
improvisation Mike Lee the uh great
director he heavily Works in
improvisation but because his is
dramatic it gets all sorts of
nominations and stuff I mean you
mentioned uh our um the guy that did in
the loop uh he also yeah
uh he did Death to Stalin a similar a
similar way of doing that one again but
when you're looking at it I'll put it
too this way if you are asking the
audience to be a voyeur on a ridiculous
situation it is much easier for that
commitment because that's the way it was
with death of Stalin you were peeking
into this political environment whereas
in the more Fantastical you make these
characters and the rest the less they
feel like they're real it's like you
have to commit to the experience and
they're not giving you enough I think to
commit to right and and The Meta nature
of it and I guess and they're doing more
I guess adult type things like they're
going in curb they're going to dinner
parties and yeah functions they're going
to opening Step Brothers they're just
sitting around watching Shark Week
exactly that's what I'm saying like
there's more like you have to get
committed to the idea of these folks
story in a film and so if it's just a
disparate sort of a grouping of set
pieces it's not going to have the same
effect as a sitcom which is intended to
be a disparate groups I wonder that you
know this uh this might be problematic
but uh are you at all watching these
guys Will Ferrell and John C Reilly in
this movie and wondering like are these
guys slightly mentally ill are they off
in some way I mean I think the the film
does a fantastic job of walking that
line without addressing it because clear
there's some sort of you know repressed
intelligence going on there because they
are intelligent in their own unique way
and but you know Forrest Gump for
instance we see Forrest as a kid and we
sort of learned what his IQ limitations
are we never really get that moment with
these two right and so but we do assume
I guess in the back subconsciously that
they went through some stuff yes when
they were kid there's a reason why their
their mom and their dad respectively are
single yeah and so they went through
some sort of trauma that was never
treated because their parents didn't
have time and they're just trying to you
know work and make a living and get a
boat to retire on and so they can't it's
a single parent household that's a lot
of work and so there's no siblings to
help kind of raise and so I think that
there is a lot of those questions and
the movie does a beautiful job of maybe
making us consider that in the back of
our head but we're having such a good
time and there's always another laugh
coming around the corner that we never
really fully have to put that thought in
the Forefront of our head we can
appreciate that there is an uncanny
valley with these characters we know
they are hitting on a different
frequency than the average person and so
there's a comedy that is built on that
but not explicitly said that makes a lot
of sense well I think uh I will add this
though 2008 was not just Step Brothers
there was enough going on that year as
far as comedy this was back when we
would get like multiple big name
comedies with big folks in it summer
hits summer misses but I want you guys
to maybe tell me if you have a film
besides Step Brothers that you would say
was like the best because I think all of
us at this point would put Step Brothers
at the top but what is your number two
amongst these get smart Tropic Thunder
You Don't Mess with the Zohan Pineapple
Express Yes Man Role Models baby mama
House Bunny Welcome Home Roscoe Jenkins
drill bit Taylor The Love Guru and Zach
and Miri Make a Porno not those last
three
not sorry but there are I think at least
one or two or three on here you can make
a good one it's being a problematic Love
Guru uh Tropic Thunder oh yeah I mean
how do are we okay with Robert Downey Jr
I think I was until he mentioned it
before he introduced black panther
yeah it's it's sort of taking on a life
of its own I think sometimes people do
take it out of context what it was doing
in the movie but I'm not gonna sit here
and defend that choice I will say the
traffic Thunder early you could take a
movie from the 90s like Ace Ventura Pet
Detective which is still hilarious in
many ways does have that a few
problematic elements now in modern
society so I think it's okay to take a
movie and say well I didn't really like
that and it's tough but there's moments
of Tropic Thunder the beginning first
all the trailers yeah are hysterical so
good Tom Cruise is less Grossman there's
so Jack Black's nut case character it
there's a lot to love in Tropic Thunder
without taking the whole kit and
caboodle oh because of that yeah the two
movies that are sort of I think
underrated that are considered quite up
there that should be are role models and
baby mama I think those were both very
funny movies and they were very they
felt very modern and they still do of
the time because baby mama is obviously
not the ideal family situation
historically and then with something
like Role Models where it's he's got
like you they were like me like you
never really wanted to even be around
kids and then you just have these you
fall into this this
plot and it really ends up being sweet
but also very funny and not always
appropriate but it still makes you laugh
out loud so role models and baby mama
are way up their Step Brothers is still
I'd say the cream of the 2008 crop
that's an impressive lineup of movies
the interesting thing to note too is
because we're talking about Will Ferrell
being like the next big star from an SNL
cast yeah you had You Don't Mess with
the Zohan and The Love Guru and that was
when we're looking at Mike Myers and
Adam Sandler wait do these guys still
have yeah
but you know who was still at the top of
her game at that point and the one that
I would pick off the list because I
agree with you on Role Models very
unreal underrated House Bunny people do
not appreciate that that had Emma Stone
in it that has still to this line people
like um sorry what's your name Mark
Mark you know what I mean like that's a
joke that I will still talk about I will
still talk about that joke that's Anna
Ferris back when she was the breadwinner
and Chris Pratt still cares like you go
watch just friends too she is such a
good underrated I think Catherine Hahn
is now is now getting the recognition
yeah what a genius she is I don't think
that Anna Faris has ever gotten the
respect that she deserves but just how
purely funny she can be um I just got a
shout out Pineapple Express James Franco
notwithstanding Pineapple Express brings
it it's so damn funny and it's
combination of comedy and action uh like
it changes tone I think I think fairly
seamlessly Danny McBride like burst onto
the scene like real hard in that movie
Seth Rogen one of the great weed movies
of all time say you can make a direct
line between tropical a Pineapple
Express and Seth's entire house plant
you know Empire
also steals scenes in Tropic Thunder
absolutely but for Pineapple Express
does that scene at the very end when
they're all clearly about to die and
they're just sitting at a diner enjoying
breakfast and they have this laugh that
just keeps going they're just laughing
at the Ridiculousness what they just
went through I was on the floor yes and
he nearly dies in the scene and they're
like did he die yeah I just love that
bit like did he die Pineapple Express
has it it's got some great laughs at the
beginning and then it it sort of gets to
this other place where you're not
laughing for 15-20 minutes and you're
kind of like what movie am I watching
Step Brothers never never too far if I
had one complaint about Step Brothers is
it I could have used one more scene with
someone like Katherine Hahn who just get
gets to gets to be that character a
little more or Andrea savage or
something like that but but but that's a
that's a minor complex Seth Rogen also a
funny Cameo yeah oh yeah what I mean you
know we always ask these questions once
every generation or so but it's like is
was that the closest that we're going to
be to a golden age of Comedy like are we
gonna get a lot of comedic movies in
theaters I was hoping that I really had
a lot of hopes for Bros is because it's
a great movie but I wanted it I wanted
it to be seen more because I love the
feeling of being in a movie theater
opening weekend and you're just rolling
with a packed out it's like being in a
comedy club and the comics just just
feeling it just in the zone I think it's
a romantic comedy but it is still a very
broad comedy I think ticket to Paradise
shows that people still want to laugh
and do it in a slightly romantic setting
because that movie this weekend with
Julia and George just swept it's going
to be a 100 million dollar movie in a
weekend so I think look Bros I saw it at
Tiff I loved it it's so funny I think
there's very clear things that many
other people have talked about but
either didn't work but yeah being scared
and laughing are things that people want
to do in a group and that will never do
oh yeah oh yeah um but I think you're on
to it I don't think we'll we will ever
have these kind of broad big comedies on
mass like we did back then like last
year like there were two bangers that
would put up against uh anything Borat 2
and Barb and star go to Vista Del Mar I
saw funny as hell and both on streaming
services yep both on streaming so we are
in a different day and age now I don't
disagree yeah and then everything is so
much more compartmentalized you might
like you know talk to some kid on the
street uh which I know both of you do
all the time uh and and there let me
give you a piece of my mind and their
favorite comedic thing is a YouTube
channel that we've never heard of and
then someone else's favorite thing is uh
is a tick tock and someone else is a
brand new streaming show they're a
comedy musician yes exactly it's we're
so broken up entertainment wise
someone's got to bring us back together
well you can even see shades of that
happening when if you chart the timeline
from what the classic comedies used to
be into something like Step Brothers
because we all talked about how you can
watch this movie in a little bit yes you
can watch this movie in Tick Tock form
and it's gonna be funny because you're
just watching very small scenes from it
but they all are gonna have multiple
jokes and they're so much bite-sized
yummy little nuggets I mean look it's uh
it's it's an old Vaudeville technique
right like these interstitials like the
idea between the set pieces you have
these two guys come out they commit to
the bit and they leave it I mean like
that's what Abbott and costell were
doing before they became Adeline yeah I
don't know this based on Comedy
knowledge I know it based on film
knowledge
because these guys are are doing they're
both sort of the the the the the the
wacky one yeah uh Lou Costello yeah and
you're just watching them play off each
other and so you need somebody to be the
butt Abbott that ends up being Mary
steenberg and Richard Jenkins yeah well
I think I think we've talked about how
much this is such a great love Fest I
love when we can have a movie where it's
just like a great love Fest of how much
we love it okay I just want to mentioned
I was just about saying what's your
final thought on stuff thank you I can't
leave without bringing up Will Ferrell
uh singing let's give him something to
talk about
and I sing that all the time I was
watching that with my wife and I and we
got in this habit of going back and
forth saying love love love
[Music]
and just the earnestness I love that
scene there's so much it's just a oh
it's just full of full of goodness this
movie Hal thank you so much sir oh what
a pleasure this was so much fun uh I did
want to ask you is there anything that
you want to tell where folks can find
you uh go ahead and let us know
absolutely uh you can follow me on
Twitter and Instagram halrudnick if you
twitch at all maybe uh see someone about
that and if you go on Twitch you can
follow me on twitch.tv slash Hal Rudnick
uh and I'm also uh hosting a show called
fail Center on Pluto TV so uh yeah a few
different places where we can enjoy each
other the [ __ ] boys tournament and
nerds yes the guy just keeps cranking
out quality content for you to see live
for you to put in your ears afterwards
thank you so much Jack of all trades I
do appreciate that I'm going to ask you
to give us one more trade though sir if
you can tell us your TV movie
recommendation our fans should uh take a
peek at since you're the man in the know
okay so it's October so I'm gonna give
you something spooky uh there have been
11 different Hellraiser movies and like
three good ones so and and the last one
I I feel like it brings it the cenobites
are just doing their cenobite hijinks
and I really enjoyed the new Hellraiser
on Hulu Hellraiser 2022 check it out the
uh perfect meal for your spooky season
oh dig I dig all right Mark uh next week
what do we got yeah next week it looks
like well first of all we didn't have a
mailbag this week but don't let that
dissuade you from letting us know you
don't forget to email us at RT is wrong
at Rotten Tomatoes we are quickly
working through the list if I have
anything to say about it uh and next
week uh we're gonna get uh we're gonna
get into the next season and we're gonna
skip over we're in spooky season right
now but the next season we're gonna
yeah we're going all the way what
jingling all the way really yeah wow
Schwarzenegger Sinbad uh that is it for
this week on Rotten Tomatoes is wrong we
will see you all next week on behalf of
Mr Mark Ellis Hal redneck Mr Brian Perez
we want to say thank you all for
listening and we'll see you all next
time
[Music]
[Music]